so many sneaky little secrets
in the supplement world hey everyone i'm
abby sharp
welcome to abby's kitchen
[Music]
today's video is sponsored by skillshare
and today we'll be looking at the
wild west world of supplements
but before we get too far into things i
want to chat about what i've been
learning
through my skillshare membership while
social distancing at home
if you haven't heard of skillshare
they're an online learning community
with
a wide range of amazing creative classes
for exploring new skills
developing interests and getting lost in
your own creativity
i know a lot of people might be thinking
about ways to learn some
new skills or diversify in their careers
especially in these really uncertain
covered times
so as a creator i've been taking diy
product photography
style and shoot creative stills by
rachel gulotta
and daniel inskeep this course has been
so awesome for helping me hone my
photography skills for good lighting
location styling and instagram
composition
so whether you're bored need some extra
self-care or want to join a creative
community while in isolation
skillshare is a great resource during
these times
and beyond and for my viewers and fans
the first
1000 people to click the link will get a
free trial of skillshare premium
membership
and after that it's only around 10 a
month and you guys can pause this video
and look at my description for my
disclaimer including a
very quick note here that this video is
not
intended to discredit all supplements or
supplement companies i'm actually a huge
supporter and consumer of supplements
and i think that they absolutely have an
essential place in
a lot of people's wellness routines so
this video is really just meant to help
you become
a more informed consumer yourself i also
want to note that i have spent a
very long time on this video trying to
uncover credible information
about this for you but i do not work
on the inside when it comes to
supplements so some of the details have
been
very hard to fully substantiate to my
personal
and professional standards so i
therefore brought in my colleague
registered dietitian
isla barmer who is an expert in
supplement regulation
because she herself is the creator of an
amazing
prenatal supplement called full circle
prenatal
so i'm gonna leave some information
below in case you're interested in that
product
even still there were definitely a few
things neither of us could get a hundred
percent clarity on
so if i learn any conflicting
information or
evidence that something i said was
incorrect or perhaps outdated
i will be updating the description with
that information so
please do take a look there when you
watch this video
alrighty folks let's talk about the
wellness supplement
industry now according to one study
150 million americans use dietary
supplements
and 10 of them are taking more than 5
every day almost 23 million people are
taking supplements in lieu of actual
drugs
and based on what i'm about to discuss
that could be a really
dangerous stat the same study also
estimated that at least
one in every 12 american adults are
taking some
kind of supplement known to cause kidney
damage while
other supplements are known carcinogens
or hormone modulators
in other words just because they're
natural
doesn't mean they're benign but let's do
a
quick little history lesson on
supplements shall we
so back in 1976 the u.s passed
legislation called the proxmer amendment
that prohibited the fda from being able
to monitor
some aspects of how dietary supplements
were made and sold
this was actually a response from
supplement companies directed at the fda
who was attempting originally to tighten
regulations
the proximity amendment also made it so
that the fda could
not classify dietary supplements as
drugs
so basically the deregulation
of supplements in the states all really
began
with this amendment right here then in
1994
we saw the passing of the dietary
supplement health and education act
or dshea now the purpose of this act
was to legally broaden the definition of
what a supplement is
and then all of the regulations that
were passed in the proximity amendment
were applicable to this new set of
products
so basically now supplements would
include
herbs botanicals amino acids enzymes
metabolites
organ tissues and glandulars and would
become available
in liquids powders gel capsules and some
bars
as opposed to just pills
now obviously nobody wants the
deregulation of prescription or
over-the-counter
medications that would probably create
some
serious major public uproar
[Music]
i guess because natural has often been
seen
as inherently healthy safe and
not corrupt by government or big pharma
there hasn't been any major push to have
this reevaluated
in fact for a lot of people who don't
trust big pharma
or other major authorities regulation
may
actually be seen as the government
meddling in there
which a lot of natural health
communities
might not want but um they probably
should
supplements even if they are natural
have actually killed people in some
cases in 1989
40 people died taking an isolated
l-tryptophan supplement
and in 2013 a weight loss supplement
called
oxyelite pro caused one death and
numerous cases of heart and liver
problems in
both of these cases the fda or the food
and drug administration had no clue what
was really going on
until ultimately it was too late
so how does the fda define a supplement
today
well supplements have become almost like
a catch-all term
for compounds that aren't considered
food or
drugs so supplements can include
vitamins
minerals herbs botanicals amino acids
enzymes metabolites glandulars and
organ tissues yep organ tissues
oh my god oh my god now do you want
better
regulations in a lot of ways you could
argue that it's kind of better for a
supplement manufacturer to be labeled
as a supplement since the fda is
far less involved in the production
marketing
and selling of a supplement thanks to
the dshea
obviously that would save a lot of these
companies a ton of money
in testing an evidence collection so
what does the supplement need to do
before appearing on your local
walgreens shelves compared to let's say
a food or a drug
well as you might expect there's
actually a lot of strict policies in
place to protect
consumers before a pharmaceutical
product reaches the market
so things like importer accountability
laws facility examinations
sample analysis and registration of
foreign products
has to occur before these
pharmaceuticals can be sold
in the country just to name a few
important steps
in fact under the pharmaceutical section
of the fda website
it explicitly states that the fda
requires that
all drugs in the united states be shown
to be both
safe and effective prior to
marketing while supplements must also
theoretically be checked for any issues
before it's put on the market
the responsibilities for safety and
labeling
are left up to the discretion of the
supplement company themselves
as opposed to being in the hands of the
fda
now the good companies take this
responsibility
really seriously because the liability
here
is potentially huge but unfortunately
some of the
not so great ones either don't bother
because
hey no one's checking their homework or
for the sake of
marketing to the consumer they may stage
studies
where they make their product look great
in a very controlled environment
arbonne is a great example of this and i
talked
all about that in my video right here
either way
75 days before products goes to market
companies
just have to send fda a little note that
suggests
why they believe that their product is
safe
the fda only gets involved in taking
action against any adulterated or
misbranded products after it reaches the
market
and considering there's close to 6 000
companies pumping out 75
000 supplements in america alone this
only really happens when there's been a
reported
problem there's just too much to police
and the fda just
doesn't have those kind of resources so
that means they're not
regularly hitting up manufacturing
plants especially
those located abroad as a lot of
supplement companies tend to source
their raw ingredients
from places like india and china they
also don't have the resources to be
checking in on the accuracy of
ingredient lists
and label claims unlike with
pharmaceuticals which
often need to undergo months of trials
and demonstrate their safety and
effectiveness prior to marketing
there are no standards on the rigor of
evidence needed to support a
supplement's marketing claim
as for the introduction of a new or a
novel ingredient into the market
this is when the fda would technically
need to be notified
if all the ingredients in a product have
been previously used in other products
or supplements
they can kind of repackage it and bring
it to the market right away
but supplement companies can often skirt
around this
too through what is now known as grass
or
g-r-a-s so grass or the generally
recognized as safe affirmation was
introduced in
1958 for use by supplement companies
and also in food now the grass
expedition
allows manufacturers to make safety
determinants that the uses of
whatever chemicals additives or other
ingredients they're putting into their
products
are generally recognized as safe
without having to necessarily notify the
fda for evaluation
or testing again owners of the
supplement companies can
choose the scientists regulators and
inspectors to
legitimize their products so for example
arbonne could theoretically hire their
own team of scientists
and researchers to conduct their own
industry-funded study
so the research isn't necessarily done
by
an unbiased third party it might still
be quality research
but it's not without bias so yeah this
may be a bit of a potentially shady
loophole to be mindful of now more
recently in 2007
the fda published a set of guidelines
called the current good manufacturing
practices
or cgmp which requires manufacturers at
cgmp facilities to test their products
to ensure
product quality confirm the absence of
contaminants
verify accuracy of labeling and more
and the fda does audit manufacturers at
cgmp facilities however in 2013
the fda inspected only about 10 of the
estimated 4
000 manufacturers covered by the cgmp
regulations
and 2.8 percent of all of the 14
995 domestic and international dietary
supplement firms
registered with the fda so looking for a
supplement company that is manufactured
in a cgmp facility is definitely
good reassurance for a consumer since
this
is an optional but rigorous program but
again
it's clearly still not perfect so yeah
supplements don't have to do a whole lot
to prove they're actually safe before
you're able to purchase them
so what should buyer be aware of
when it comes to purchasing supplements
here are some
really important things i want you to
know
number one they don't have to list any
side effects or interactions
basically the onus is on you as a
consumer or patient
to know what you can and can't take with
a particular supplement
or for your doctor to somehow keep tabs
on
all your supplements and then warn you
of how they may
interact with other medications or
conditions
but despite me always suggesting that
you speak to your doctor before starting
a supplement regimen
how many of you actually do
that's why you have your hand up
well in some cases starting a new
vitamin
could actually have some major health
repercussions
for example st john's wort a very common
supplement used for depression and
anxiety and menopause
actually interferes with about 50 of
prescription drugs on the market
including birth control and
pharmaceutical antidepressants
so yeah i would bet there have been
quite a few oopsie moments related to
this
herb hello no
there it is number two companies can
often hide behind proprietary blends
i talked about the frustration of these
proprietary blends in my video on
shakeology right here
but essentially even if you are in the
know
on what herbs and vitamins are safe for
you
you might not even know what you're
getting
if the ingredients are packaged under
the guise of
a proprietary blend number three
supplements may theoretically be
marketed at any concentration
as long as the daily recommended value
if available
is specified on the label so one example
of this
is vitamin b12 which is often sold in
2500 microgram doses aka
1 000 times more than a person
theoretically needs in one day now i
know that for many of you
this might sound like a good thing right
like the more vitamins and minerals we
eat
the better right well
not exactly tolerable upper intake
levels
actually exist for most vitamins and
minerals and even water-soluble vitamins
which can be excreted in
excess and theoretically should be
relatively harmless
can potentially have some dangerous
repercussions in certain situations
so in the case of vitamin b12 which
again you would just normally pee right
out
getting too much or too little in
pregnancy has been linked to
autism so more doesn't necessarily
always equal better
and it's really best not to
self-medicate and to consult a
healthcare professional
about your unique individual needs
number four
raw natural ingredients are often
sourced internationally
and often are hard to carefully
manipulate measure or control
unlike pharmaceuticals which are
carefully measured and compounded
in a lab nature is not always so precise
this can result in major discrepancies
about how much of a nutrient
actually ends up in a product compared
to what the label
actually says reports have suggested
that
overages and underages in supplements
are surprisingly
a common phenomenon one review recently
published in the journal of nutrition
showed that certain supplements tend to
have ingredient overages
of 20 percent or more specifically
a lot of multivitamins had approximately
10 to 20 percent more calcium
than their label had stated and unknown
to many
consuming too much calcium for some
people can cause
a number of adverse consequences like
constipation
and potentially kidney stones finally in
addition to discrepancies in ingredient
amounts
there's often the risk of actual
contaminants in supplements
where they ultimately do not belong
in 2010 u.s government accountability
office report
analyzed 40 different dietary
supplements looking for the presence of
lead
arsenic mercury cadmium or pesticides
the results showed that at least trace
amounts of at least one or more of these
contaminants
were found in 93 of those samples
in the case of botanicals there can be
huge variation
in strength and quality depending on the
genetic variation
or environmental conditions of the
plants of origin
one study reported that 59 of tested
botanical supplements
contained plant species not even listed
on the label
and that active ingredient substitution
was observed among
83 percent of companies tested
uh yikes so we have established
that supplements may or may not always
contain what they
claim to contain and may or may not
be healthy or safe for you depending on
a
wide range of unregulated factors but
what about how they're marketed to you
well turns out that can be a little bit
shady too
[Music]
in 1994 the dshea that we discussed
came up with structure function claims
so unlike drugs supplements are not
permitted to be marketed for the purpose
of
treating diagnosing preventing or curing
diseases so that's good so they can't
say that something
cures heart disease or lowers
cholesterol or reverses
erectile dysfunction what they can do
is use words like supports or targets
and that's why we often see supplements
with verbiage like
supports a healthy immune system or
targets our stress response
you may also notice that any claims that
they do make
need to be accompanied by a itty-bitty
little disclaimer
that these statements have not been
approved by the fda
so you've probably all seen that line a
lot
or if you haven't now you will now
before i get into how to choose a
reputable supplement i quickly want to
flag that
what i'm discussing largely is about
american regulations
i cannot speak to how supplements are
regulated in europe
or the uk and it's only slightly
different
here where i am in canada so
very quickly supplements in canada are
licensed as natural health products or
nhps which help to create safe product
formula standards
dosages and claims about usage nhps have
approved blurbs
about ingredients on packages that
include a little bit more detail about
ingredient types dosages and claims of
the product
there are also a few more details
provided about specific dietary
ingredients
also things like nutrients and other
substances that a supplement would have
on their label
and canadian regulations actually
license all of the businesses
involved in manufacturing holding
processing
and distributing a supplement finally
there's a legal
dietary ingredient database that exists
in canada where
all legitimate and licensed ingredients
are registered
unfortunately even with all of these
safeguards in place
this system is far from perfect
the standards are pretty low for what
passes as an effective supplement
marketing regulation is total crap
and there is a major backlog in adverse
event reports to health canada
so that it can take a very long time for
something to be
taken off the market so maybe not as bad
as the states
but still really not great so i know
that i may have
freaked you guys out a bit but i want to
remind you
that supplements are not bad and
supplement companies are
not all out to scam you or to make you
sick
absolutely not i think supplements are
vitally
important in a lot of cases it's just a
matter of finding the
right one for your needs so what should
you be aware of when
choosing your supplements number one
look for a third party tested product
i like to use websites like labdor
informed choice
and nsf sport to look for a product that
has been
tested by a company other than the one
that you're
buying it from to look for impurities
accuracy of labeling and
quality labdoor for example will send a
sample of each product to an fda
registered lab
for detailed chemical analysis which
includes
measurements of active ingredients and
potential contaminants
some sports supplements will include
certifications on their products
packaging such as
nsf or informed choice labels which are
intended to provide
assurance that the product has been
tested by respected
independent certification organizations
so that's something i recommend looking
for when you can
and if you can't find your go-to
supplement on one of these websites
you can email their support team and ask
to see
proof of their third-party testing
number two
use non-commercial websites to learn
about supplement ingredients
credible authorities like nih fda
and usda often have fact sheets
about common ingredients and their
respective evidence which
provides a more unbiased source on the
legitimacy
of some marketing claims compared to the
brand's websites
which we now know is not so well
regulated
number three know that if a claim sounds
too good to be true
it probably is so be mindful of product
claims such as
works better than a prescription drug or
it's 100
safe or has zero side effects if these
supplements have enough
of an effect on the body to work
they also have the potential for
unwanted side effects
next be aware that the term natural
doesn't always mean
safe so as we mentioned there's lots of
potential for interactions
and contraindications depending on your
unique health status
don't forget that supplements are never
meant to replace an
actual healthy diet or pharmaceuticals
when needed
so i always prefer to think of
supplements as complementary not
supplementary in the quest for good
health don't forget to
always speak to your health care
provider before starting
any supplement regimen and finally
report any serious side effects or
issues associated with a supplement
to the fda as soon as possible
your reporting could potentially save
someone else
or many people from serious harm by
getting an
unsafe or misleading product off the
shelves asap
in conclusion a reminder that i am not
insinuating that supplements are bad
i buy and i take a lot of supplements
but i also know what a wild west rodeo
it is out there
so i am sharing this information to help
you
become more informed consumers i'm
planning to hopefully make this into a
whole series where i look at different
kinds of supplements
and categorize them as yay or nay in my
books
so leave me a comment below if there's a
product that you take
that you want me to potentially review
and on that note
that is all that i have for you guys
today thanks again to skillshare for
sponsoring this video
if you liked it be sure to give it the
thumbs up leave me a comment below
subscribe to the channel and i'll see
you next time on abby's kitchen
[Music]
bye
[Music]
you